here with more florida senator marco
rubio is with us senator thank you for
being here
i don't have all the answers but i i do
know this senator
that
if we
the ukrainian people have shown the
willingness to courageously fight back
if we give them the javelins we give
them intelligence we give them stinger
missiles and i would argue give them the
migs and give them the jets that they
want i'm confident that they could do a
good enough job with their insurgency
uh back against putin what are your
thoughts
yeah i think you're seeing that play out
look i mean the russians are bringing to
bear about 65 percent 60 65 percent of
their entire conventional forces are now
inside the country of ukraine after 20
years of massive increases in defense
spending
i think you're seeing a couple things
bad planning no doubt about it i think
you're also seeing that some of the
russian equipment isn't as good as
advertised but the last thing you're
seeing is probably the most important is
that will to fight and that's not
something that's easily measured you
know you you can't either i don't think
putin or the russian military thought
that ukrainians would fight the way they
have right now and they're playing
defense they're in a defensive position
which has allowed them for example for
weeks to build up defenses around kiev
so i don't think the russians are going
to be able to go in and take any of
these cities they may be able to level
them like you were just saying but take
them that's that's going to be a tough
task especially kiev
so we have afghanistan we know the
disaster that that became
we had over the weekend of ballistic
missiles from iran slamming into a base
in iraq
but they're saying oh we weren't the
target i'm not sure i buy that china is
warning of the worst consequences of any
country that supports taiwan militarily
senator you know as well as i do that we
have an agreement with taiwan and uh we
are an ally of taiwan are we going to
abandon them next
you know sean i think what this is
reminding us of is if you look at the
history of mankind about 5500 years of
written history it's largely been the
story of authoritarianism what we have
here in america you were saying it in
your monologue at the outset is very
rare and unique almost all of human
history has been about authoritarianism
and history didn't end at the fall of
the soviet union and now you have
authoritarians in charge and some pretty
powerful countries like russia like
china and then they have nuclear weapons
in places like north korea and like and
they're trying to get them in iran and
so what you're seeing here is a number
of countries testing america testing
freedom they view this as their
opportunity right now to expand for a
lot of different reasons they see
weakness in the white house they see
distractions and and complacency in the
west and uh are we suppo yeah i mean do
i believe the american people are
prepared to do what it takes to defend
taiwan absolutely but just know we're
not going to have the same options to
sanction china that we've had to
sanction russia which reminds us why we
need to protect begin to protect our own
economy one thing is to get cut off of
the russian economy but right now we
depend way too much on china for the
things we buy we have to stop that
senator i i still for the life of me
can't get over the negotiations brokered
by russia and china between the u.s and
iran
and that would transfer tens of billions
of dollars to the muellers in iran make
them rich right off the bat but then we
would be
possibly according to pete butterjudge
the
genius that he is with all the
experience he has
importing oil maybe from from iran then
possibly lifting sanctions with
venezuela and maduro a murdering
dictator thug
and still joe has been begging opec to
increase their energy production
they keep turning him down and he
doesn't turn to texas alaska and
oklahoma
for oil and he doesn't turn to west
virginia and ohio and pennsylvania for
gas why not
because these guys have an agenda that
becomes an object of like religious
worship right so like we have to sign
the deal with iran they're so obsessed
with it no matter what else is happening
in the world we've got to get that iran
deal done it doesn't matter how many
people they kill how many terrorist
attacks to carry out we got to do that
the same with the you know the green new
deal uh and so forth they're they're so
obsessed with it that on the one hand no
matter who we have to buy oil from as if
somehow a barrel of oil from saudi
arabia were cleaner than a barrel of oil
from the united states no matter who we
have to buy from let's buy it from them
let's beg them for it but let's not
produce it here in america so that we
can say well at least it isn't art oil
that's destroying the environment i mean
it's just lunacy it's nonsense it's left
us vulnerable the american people see
what common sense decisions are but
these guys can't make that decision
because they got radicals in charge of
the democratic party
why are you against the no-fly zone
well i just think the no-fly zone
frankly is not what people think it is
it's not it it would require going to
war with russia we would have to go
after all of their anti-aircraft their
surface-to-air missile but not just in
ukraine we'd have to go after them in
russia we'd have to go after them in
belarus you'd have to be willing to
shoot down any airplanes that interest
that that fly over the the air in
ukraine so i just i don't think a lot of
people fully understand no fly zones are
not some faa rule that's put out there
they have to be enforced you have to
actually go out and be willing to shoot
people down and in the case of russia
you're going to have to knock out their
surface-to-air missiles this is not
syria this is not iraq i mean these guys
have real surface-to-air missiles and i
just think before we go to world war iii
which is what that would be we have to
be prepared to and we have to be
prepared to understand clearly what
we're talking about doing here
all right senator this is very fluid all
around the world thank you for being
with us senator marco rubio now